Reason number two
that I'm
running is
because we cannot allow Donald Trump
to be the Republican nominee again.
We simply can't.
And the reason we can't, it's
not only because he'll lose to Joe Biden,
although that's the first reason.
But the second reason is he let us down.
Let's be honest about it.
I stood on those stages in 2016
and those debates.
I participated in them.
I was up here in New Hampshire
working hard and campaigning
And I remember the things he said.
Let's talk
about just three of his main promises
from 2016 promise one
I will repeal and replace Obamacare
and we came a Republican Congress
to do it
we tell everybody
I was governor of Jersey for eight years
I didn't have a Republican legislature
for 5 minutes of those eight years
I would have given my right arm
for one week.
Tom with you
as Senate president in New Jersey
you would never see that
we were working for that whole week.
He had a Republican Congress
and he did repeal to replace Obamacare.
And you want to know why
in the end we lost by one vote.
One vote.
Whose vote was it?
John McCain's?
And why didn't John McCain vote that way?
Because Donald Trump from 2015
forward insulted John McCain
every chance he had said he wasn't a war
hero.
Insulted his time when he ran
for president,
insulted his service in the Senate,
went to Arizona and said
anybody who's a McCain person
can't be with me.
His own selfishness
and self-centeredness
cost us repeal
and replace one of Obamacare.
So we still have Obamacare today.
Second,
This is my favorite one
he's going to build
the biggest, most beautiful wall
you have ever seen from one end
to the border to the next
And Mexico's going to pay for it.
Well, let's review the performance
he built 52
new miles of wall in four years.
52 miles
he says, Now
reelect me and I'll get it all done.
Well, if he goes at the same pace,
that he went his first four years,
he only needs 110 more years
as president of the United States
to finish the entire wall
And if you are waiting for the first peso
to be delivered
from Mexico to even pay for the 52 miles
that we got, it hadn't come.
And I will tell you
back in 20, 15,
I met with the president of Mexico
at that time, President Pena Nieto,
and I asked him
what he thought about the wall
and he said, well, we're not big fans.
He said, But
it's your side of the border.
You can do whatever you want,
but let me promise
you one thing, Governor.
We're never, ever, ever paying for
it, ever.
And not only
has he kept that promise,
but so is his successor, as well.
And so
if he said he's going to fix
the immigration system,
how's it look, though, to fix to me.
But worse than that fact
that he didn't achieve it,
he never even proposed
a piece of legislation
to fix our broken immigration system.
Promise.
Number three,
I am a businessman
and I will balance the budget
in four years
by cutting wasteful Washington spending
in four years.
He added $6 trillion to the national debt
6 trillion in four years.
He ran up more debt
in one term
than any president in American history.
And we shouldn't be surprised
when he runs his business.
Well, that's right.
And I was just going to give you
an example of that.
I'm going to take you on the road
with me all the time.
He's teaming up
because, you know, he had a business.
He had businesses in New Jersey
when I was governor.
He had casinos in Atlantic City,
and they went bankrupt three times.
Now, let me ask you something.
How stupid do you have to be
to lose money in a casino?
The only people who lose money
in the casino are us.
I remember when I first time
ever went to Atlantic City,
my father took me there
when that city was the only other place
other than Nevada that had casinos
and I went in to the casino
and I was 18 years old.
So I was allowed to play and I won
50 bucks playing blackjack.
I thought I was the hottest thing
in the world.
And my father said, Well,
let's go for a walk outside
for a little while. Take a break.
So he took me outside.
We were walking on the boardwalk
in Atlantic City,
and he said,
I want you to see all you look at all
these big, beautiful hotels.
I said, Yeah,
because they don't build those because
you win
but even with that advantage,
Donald Trump
had to go bankrupt three times.
And then I'll give you one story
for when I was governor,
when I became governor
and holed up eating there.
Okay, Jim,
because he's going to fall over on this.
I had $11 billion
deficit that I inherited
on a $29 billion budget night.
11 billion deficit.
And when this all came out publicly,
and we were having to try to deal
with balancing it,
my friend Donald Trump called me back.
This is in 2010 with a suggestion
he said to me, Chris, go bankrupt.
I certainly understand Donald's
states are not allowed to go bankrupt.
And he goes, No, no, I know.
Just do it anyway.
He said, it'll be tied up in the courts
for years,
he said,
and then everyone will just remember
that you fought
to not have to pay this money.
And if whenever the courts figure out,
then they figure it out.
But you look like a winner.
That was his suggestion to me.
So should we be surprised that he ran up
$6 trillion in debt in four years?
And what do you think
he'll do
when he never has to answer to you again?
He's got four years to do
whatever he wants.
See, I'm for many of his policies.
I remember
I was the first one to endorse him
after he dropped out of the race.
I chaired his transition.
I chaired his opioid and drug
abuse commission.
So keep you up at night.
I played Hillary
Clinton in debate prep in 2016.
Was oh yes
you know
I'll make your comments later and
in 2020 I played Joe
Biden in debate prep
I took a couple of sedatives before I did
but I did
so I'm not
some never Trumper
I am against him
because he let us down on the issues
that he made us the biggest promises on
if you like Donald Trump's policies
why in the hell would you ever hire him
to make sure they happened.
He's already proven he can't do it.
And if you think next
time is going to be easier than last
time,
I will tell you no chance
because of all of his other conduct.
So I want to be clear
that I oppose him
for his incompetence.
I oppose him for his broken promises
before we ever get
any of the criminal indictments.